[Música]
y
vamos
[Música]
son sus demandas
es indicio liza
xavi
[Música]
con él
por eso
weiss
[Música]
son tres meses
yo no sé
[Música]
escribe
a los
[Música]
y te diste usted
en esas
[Música]
seis meses
s
[Música]
i
después meses
[Música]
mantenerse
sin ciencia
[Música]
muchas gracias
el tema este de tener que mantener el
equilibrio mientras intento hacer cosas
con el pedal con los nervios no lo llevo
muy bien así que si me caigo
[Música]
incorporo algo de humor en el momento
tex avery notado en esta canción he
hecho algo de trampa a mis que tengo
y una de mis mejores amigas le llamó mi
magic box porque para mí él me permite
hacer magia en vivo
de una manera un poco más real hace
varios años veía que músicos con los que
colaboraba llenaban esos huecos
musicales que había dentro de mi cabeza
que
luego cuando los quitaban me sentía
vacía sentía como que no estaba haciendo
lo suficiente en el escenario sabía que
había posibilidades que no tenía las
maneras de hacerlas no tenía tres
coristas detrás cantando conmigo no
tenía un batería guiñando me y entonces
invertir algo de tiempo e intente
averiguar cómo poder hacer que una
canción se construyera en vivo
rápidamente algo rápido para que todos
vosotros que no entendáis cómo funciona
en simples simplemente un botón
[Música]
pues un botón
y al pulsar el botón empieza a grabarse
entonces puedo hacer
y luego al pulsar el botón de nuevo que
acabo de grabar el pulsar el botón de
nuevo
[Música]
de nuevo
es muy simple
[Música]
bueno cuando me pidieron
componer algo animado para
animado y feliz que es algo que se me da
bastante mal tengo tendencia de las
canciones melancólicas bueno esta
canción sin querer la compuse muy
rápidamente
espero que os guste
[Música]
i
sí
[Música]
d
a mí
i
y si son dos
aquí
si ya tiene una fábrica de silicio
siendo mitad
[Música]
sí
así sobreviviente
no
[Música]
a
de semanas
baby
[Música]
desde el sol 1
nosotros
[Música]
el lugar es grande
bien
[Música]
sí sí sí sí
sí
así
sí sí sí sí sí
[Música]
a través de aviones como
el avión es una clave más como
nada es así
[Música]
la vida
i
ah
sí
clave
es así
[Música]